[Müzik]
şimdi birazdan burada 3 adet yan yana p
harfi göreceğiz arkamda gördüğünüz bu 3p
aslında bu salondaki sıradan herhangi
bir kişiye şu an rastgele sorsam bu hiç
penin anlamını Muhtemelen bilmiyorum
yanıtını alacağım ama aslına bakarsanız
bu salondaki Herkes bu 3p'nin anlamını
biliyor onu her gün bir şekilde görüyor
duyuyor bazılarımız onu kullanıyor fakat
herkes onun anlamını bilmesine karşın
neredeyse kimse onu bildiğini bilmiyor
bu 3 peynir ne olduğuna Birazdan
geleceğiz ve bu düğümü birlikte
çözeceğiz Ama önce biraz geçmişe gidelim
benim lise yıllarında iken tek bir
hedefim vardı İstanbul Teknik
Üniversitesi'nde inşaat mühendisliği
okumak üniversite sınavına girdim ilk
tercihimi yaptım İlk tercihimi ilk
inşaatı yazdım ve kazandım o gün tahmin
edeceğiniz gibi Hayatımın en mutlu
günüydü
daha sonra tabii ki Ders süreci başladı
ve ilk dönem bir gün bir teknik resim
dersinde inanılmaz derecede Canım
sıkıldı Moralim bozuldu dersi falan
dinlemeyi bıraktım camdan dışarıyı
seyretmeye başladım
tam anlamıyla Bir Hayal kırıklığıydı
yıllarca uğrunda çabaladığım emek sarf
ettiğim
onu aslında hep o eleştirdiğimiz Türk
eğitim sisteminin neredeyse bir
yansımasıydı dedim ki Kadir bir hata mı
yaptın yanlış bir yola mı girdin acaba
Yol yakınken geri mi dönmeliyiz
o an tam bir film kesti gibiydi Aslında
zeki demirkubuzun masumiyet filminde
Haluk Bilginer'in bir kiradı vardır
Bekir karakteri bir ikileme düşer ve
şöyle söyler oğlum Bekir dedim kendi
kendime kaderin böyle yol belli Ey
başını usul usulü şimdi o gün bugündür
usul usul yürüyorum İşte derbikir ben de
o ikileme düştüğüm günden beri inşaat
mühendisliğinin akademik alanında
usul usul yürüyor lakin benim Bekir'den
bir farkım var her şeyi kadere çevredeki
olumsuz koşullara bağlamak yerine tüm
bunların varlığını kabul ederek ama
onlara karşı bir şeyler de yaparak
usul usulü yürümeliyim diyorum O gün o
sınıfı da bu kararlılıkta terk ettim ve
4 sene boyunca İTÜ İnşaat fakültesinde
bir daha hiçbir ikileme düşmeden
eğitimimi tamamladım sonra tabi
Türkiye'deki her yeni mezun genç gibi
benim için de Sudan Çıkmış balık evresi
geldi şimdi ne yapacağım diye düşünmeye
başladım maalesef lisans eğitimini
tamamladığımızda birçoğumuz araştırma
yapmayı eleştirel düşünmeyi sorgulamayı
hala öğrenememiş oluyor Ben kendimi de
böyle hissediyordum mezun olduğumda ve
dedim ki yüksek lisans yapmalıyım Çünkü
artık orada bir şeyler yazmaya
başlıyoruz ortaya bir tez atıyoruz
Peki hangi alanda yüksek lisans
yapacağım bunu düşünmeye başladım Öyle
bir alan olmalıydı ki disiplinler arası
olmalı bana problem görmeyi öğretmeli
problem çözmeyi Analiz yapmayı öğretmeli
Düşündüm taşındım ve inşaat projeleri
yönetimi alanını seçtim yani İnşaat
mühendisiyle Proje yönetiminin kesişimi
Multi disipliner bir alan
dersler başladıktan sonra tabii test
süreci geliyor bir süre sonra lisanstaki
çok daha keyifli bir eğitim sürecim oldu
daha doğru bir alanı seçtiğim için
sürecine geldiğimde Benim yolum
başlangıçta gördüğümüz o 3 P ile kes
şimdi Gelin bu düğümü yavaş yavaş
çözmeye başlayalım
bu 3p yani ppp public privat Partner
Ship demek kamu özel işbirliği bir
inşaat projesi teslim yöntemi aynı
zamanda bir proje finansmanı yöntemi
Türkiye'de son 15-20 yıldır yapışta
devret olarak bilinen türü çok sık
uygulanıyor dünyada da yine Gelişmekte
olan ülkelerin çok tercih ettiği bir
model Peki model nasıl işliyor diyelim
ki Gelişmekte olan bir ülkeyiz ve 3
milyar dolarlık bir köprü yapacağız
hazinemizde bu köprüyü yapabilecek
miktarda bir kaynak olmayabilir O zaman
ne yapabiliriz Finans kuruluşlarına
gidebiliriz fakat Finans kuruluşlarına
gittiğimizde yüksek faizlerle bir kredi
almak zorunda kalacağız
Ayrıca yarın öbür gün daha Elzem bir
borca ihtiyaç duyduğumuzda zaten önceden
bir Borcumuz olduğu için daha da yüksek
faize borçlanacağız Yani bir bireyin
sürekli kredi çekip kısır bir döngüye
girmesi gibi böyle olunca alternatif
modelimiz ppp beliriyor bizim ihtiyaç
duyduğumuz bu 3 milyar doların yaklaşık
%70'ini yüzde seksenini Finans kurumları
karşılıyor yine kalan %20 %30'u ise
yatırımcı sponsor inşaat şirketi
dediğimiz şirketler getiriyor masaya
koyuyor sonra o parayla projeyi
yapıyorlar köprü hayata geçti bu
köprüden araçlar geçmeye başlıyor geçiş
ücretlerini Bu şirket topluyor Yani
orayı işletiyor ve ardından o ücretlerle
bankanın ana parasını faizini ödüyor
ardından da kendi koyduğu parayı belirli
bir kar marjıyla geri alıyor tesis
devlete geçiyor işletme süresi sonunda
devletin cebinden şu ana kadar bir kuruş
dahi çıkmadı
ne düşünüyorsunuz bilmiyorum Ama bana
kalırsa tüm zamanların en iyi
kurgulanmış iş modellerinden biri Fakat
çok iyi kurgulanmış iş modellerinin de
açık noktaları olabilir ve oradan
yakalandıkları takdirde arkalarında
devasa bir enkaz bırakabilirler ne demek
istiyorum devlet olarak o 3 milyar
dolarlık köprüyü yaptırırken
yatırımcıların ilgisini çekmek projeyi
onlara daha fizibil kılmak için bazen
devletler şunu yapıyor diyor ki mesela
yılda buradan 3 milyon araç geçeceğini
ben size taahhüt ediyorum diyor fakat
bir milyon araç geçtiğini varsayalım
aradaki 2 milyon araçtan kaynaklanan
maddi farkı devlet hazineden Yani
hepimizin ortak kasasından cebinden Bu
şirketler ödüyor
İşte o zaman Tahmin edeceğiniz üzere Bu
model çok tartışılmaya başlanıyor
Türkiye dışında diğer Gelişmekte olan
Ülkelerde de tartışılan bir model bunu
görünce dedim ki bu konu çok kritik bir
konu Ayrıca bahsettiğim pazar
trilyonlarca dolarlık bir pazar ben bu
konu üzerine çalışmalıyım dedim ve o
yüzden bu konuyu seçtim
şuna baktım konuyu çalışacağım ama konu
çok geniş neresinden tutacağım geçmişe
döndüm küçüklükten beri uyguladığım bir
yöntemi uygulamaya karar verdim
Ortaokulda lisede biyoloji derslerinde
mesela fotosentezi çalışırken gidip
direkt onun tanımını okumak yerine açar
onu etkileyen faktörleri okurdu çünkü
onları iyice anlarsam kavrarsam büyük
resmi daha kolay görebilirim
çıkarımlarımı daha kolay yapabilirim
Burada da aynı yöntemi izledim gittim bu
projeleri etkileyen faktörlere baktım ne
bu faktörler riskler mesela devlet Biraz
önce çok ciddi bir yükümlülük altına
girdi bir risk maliyetlerde sapma
olabilir proje zamanında
tamamlanmayabilir proje yapılırken
ülkede hükümet değişebilir seçimde yeni
gelen hükümet projeye karşı tutum
takınabilir daha sayabileceğimiz 100'e
yakın risk var ama bazı riskler çok daha
büyük etkiler ortaya koyuyor mesela
artık her gün hayatımızda deneyimlemeye
başladığımız ne yazık ki döviz kuru
riski gibi
Devletin 1 milyar dolarlık bir
yükümlülük altına girdiğini düşünelim
dolar 7 lirayken borcumuz 7 milyar lira
Ama bugün dolar 17 lira olduğunda
borcumuz artık 17 milyar lira sadece bir
risk faktöründen kaynaklı olarak 10
milyarlarca liralık ek bir yükümlülük
altına girme durumu gerçekleşebiliyor
işte bunu da görünce dedim ki Kadir
zaten doğru noktadan başlamışsın yani
konunun esas önemli kısmı burası burada
bir değer ortaya koyarsak buradan önemli
bir çıkarım yapabiliriz yaptığımız
çalışma bir noktaya ulaşır ve yüksek
lisan sezimde literatür taraması yaptım
bu konu üzerine baktım Bu riskleri Derli
toplusundan bir yapı yok dedim ki
tezimin çıktısı bu olsun bir şablon
tasarladım bir kanvas risk analiz
kalması ve onu tezemin çıktısı olarak
koydum Sonra dedim ki Madem bu pazar bu
kadar büyük benim bu pazarda daha da
uzmanlaşmam lazım ve doktora yapmaya
karar verdim yine itü'de bu konu üzerine
Doktora da şu anda Bu risklerin çok daha
efektif bir şekilde sözel bir şekilde
analiz edilmesini sağlayacak ve o
projelerde ortaya çıkacak milyonlarca
dolarlık zararın önüne geçmeyi
destekleyecek Bir yazılım geliştirmeye
çalışıyorum yakın zamanda bir prototip
Ortaya koymuş olacağım ama asıl önemli
olan şey şu; bu süreçte öylesine bir
problem deneyimledim ve bu problem
Aslında beni o kadar rahatsız etti ki
size biraz bu problemden bahsetmek
istiyorum Bugün
taraflarından birisi Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti'nin idari kurumları olan bu
bahsettiğim pp sözleşmelerinin içeriğine
ne ben bir araştırmacı olarak ne de
İçimizden herhangi birisi Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti vatandaşı olarak
erişemiyoruz içeriye Aslında bizim
yaşantımız üzerinde bu kadar etkili olan
o maddeleri o detayları göremiyoruz özel
hukuk kapsamına girdiği ve ticari esir
olduğu gerekçesiyle
şunu söyleriz değil mi günümüzde bilgiye
ulaşmak çok kolay Saniyeler içerisinde
aradığımız her bilgiye ulaşıyoruz işte
öyle olmadığının delillerinden bir
tanesi Aslında bu
şimdi kısa süreliğine bir kenara
bırakalım birazdan onun üzerinden yine
çok çarpıcı bir örnek vereceğim ama
hepimizin deneyimleyeceği başka bir
örnek vereyim bilgiye ulaşma
noktasındaki sorunlarla alakalı Şimdi
Her sene bayram tatili yaklaşırken
yazarız internete Bayram tatili ne zaman
9 gün olacak mı Sonra haber siteleri
çıkar karşımıza tıklarız Onlardan bir
tanesine karşımıza çıkan içerik şöyle
başlar bayram tatili ne zaman Bayram
tatili kaç gün olacak bayram tatili 9
gün olacak mı Bayram tatilinin 9 gün
olup olmayacağı açıklandı mı bu şekilde
gider aşağı doğru uzar uzar kendini
tekrar eder en son kıyılda köşede bir
yerde kısmen aradığınız şeye bir yanıt
görürüz orada şöyle yazar Bayram
tatilinin 9 gün olup olmayacağı henüz
açıklanmadı
dakikalarca Biz o bilginin peşinde
koştuk belki O sitede gündemdeki bir
magazin haberini popüler Bir videoyu
gördük onlara tıkladık ve 20-25 dakika
kaybettik Halbuki biz bilgiyi arıyorduk
bilginin peşindeydik ve onu ararken
kaybolduk Çünkü bugün Normalde Asli
görevi halka bilgiye ulaştırmak olan
gazetelerde dahi ajanstan hazır bir
içeriği alıyor onu Biraz önce söylediğim
saçma sapan içerik yaklaşımıyla arama
motor optimizasyonuna uygun hale
getiriyor ve daha fazla reklam
görebileceğimiz şekilde bizim önümüze
sunuyor Yani asıl vazifesi mesaj iletmek
olan mecra bile daha çok artık reklam
yapmayı ve Oradan gelir elde etmeye
hedefliyor
şimdi bu probleme ek olarak pppler
üzerinden başka çarpıcı bir örnek
vereyim Zafer Havalimanı Kütahya'da
yapıldı basında karşınıza bu Havalimanı
ile alakalı çeşitli haberler çıkmıştır
Türkiye'nin en büyük havalimanlarından
birisi ve ppp modeliyle yapıldı arkadaki
tabloda bu havalimanında verilen
garantilerde nedenli bir sapma olduğunu
görüyorsunuz Hani Biraz önce söyledim ya
köprüden araç geçiş garantileri
veriliyordu Burada da giden yolcu
garantisi verilmiş Bunlar resmi
verilerden benim hesapladığım kırmızı
tutumu Ben hesapladım resmi verilerden
hesaplanmış tablo ve gördüğünüz gibi
işletilmeye başlandıktan beri 10 yıl
boyunca her yıl minimum %90'lık bir
sapma var 98-99 sapmalar var yani bir
milyon yolcu garantisi verildiyse
havalimanına Örneğin %98 satmada sadece
20.000 kişi kullanmış
bu akıl alabilecek bir şey değil kabul
edilebilir bir şey değil Özellikle
taraflarından birisi kamu olan bir
sözleşmede kesinlikle kabul edilebilir
değil ama bunu bu şekilde eleştiremeyiz
yaptığım gibi ne yapmamız gerekiyor
gidip sözleşmesine bakmamız gerekiyor
gidip o Tablodaki sayıları nasıl
hesapladıklarını talep modelinden
görmemiz gerekiyor ve bir temellendirme
eşliğinde fikrimizi savunup bunu da
halka iletmemiz gerekiyor Mesela ben
bunu yapmak isterim ama yapamıyorum niye
yapamıyorum çünkü diyorum ya o bilgiye
erişim sorunu yaşıyorum o bilgi Aslında
bizle paylaşılmıyor
bunları gördükten sonra düşündükten
sonra Bu bilgiye erişim problemini bir
adım öteye taşımaya karar verdim Dedim
ki Kadir bunları söylüyorsun ediyorsun
eleştiriyorsun Tamam bilgi az olabilir
Peki senin de içinde bulunduğun oluşum
yani Akademi dediğimiz Yapı var olan o
limitli bilgiye halka indirme noktasında
ne derece Mahir
maalesef buna da pek olumlu bir yanıt
veremiyorum Bunu size şöyle anlatayım
lisede edebiyat derslerinin hep ilk
konusu şudur sanat sanat için mi sanat
toplum içinde bunu hep tartışırız fakat
hiçbir zaman bilim toplum için mi yoksa
bilim bilim için mi diye bir tartışmaya
girdiğimizi ben anımsamıyorum çünkü
yanıtı çok net bilim toplum için
hepimizin sürekli olarak ilerlemesi için
ama çok ciddi bir gönül rahatsızlığıyla
söyleyebilirim ki Türkiye'de durum pek
böyle olmuyor birkaç örnekle anlatayım
yine mesela akademik konferanslar
yapılıyor Türkiye'de gidiyorsunuz bu
konferanslara Tıpkı Burası gibi kocaman
5-6 tane salon
konferansın ikinci gününden itibaren o
salonlara uğradığınızda içeride sadece
4-5 kişi görüyorsunuz Kim o 4-5 kişi
biliyor musunuz O gün orada sunum
yapacak akademisyenler diğer
akademisyenler nerede onlar Konferansı
daha çok turistik bir faaliyet olarak
değerlendirmeyi tercih ediyor buraya
kadar gelmişken bölgeyi Biraz gezelim
diyorlar
böyle bir yerden bilim çıkmasını bekler
misiniz
Eğer gerçekçi olacaksak ki Türkiye'de
Bence artık gerçekçi olmamızın vakti
geldi ben pek pek demiyorum
bir başka örnek Türkiye'de birçok yüksek
lisans tezi yazılıyor doktora tezi
yazılıyor bildiriler makaleler yazılıyor
kaç tanesi bir şekilde bize ulaşıyor
bizim için bir değer ortaya koyuyor
yazılan tezlerin çoğunun kaderi
üniversite kütüphanesine bir nüshasının
kaldırılması ve orada yıllarca sararmayı
beklemek şeklinde ilerliyor o tezleri
çoğu zaman yazan kişi dışında kimse
okumuyor test hocası ve tez jürisi dahil
Türkiye'de Bunlar Hiç konuşulmuyor hep
görmezden geliniyor halının altına
süpürülüyor Ama gerçeğin üstünü ne kadar
örtersek örtelim Onun bir şekilde
kendini belli etme özelliği var ya zaten
ülke olarak İçinde bulunduğumuz bilimden
bilimsellikten Uzak dururum Aslında
Söylediğim şeylerin birer ispatı olarak
kendini fazlasıyla belli ediyor
bu problemlerin bahsettiğim konuların
bir kısmını deneyimleyince bir kısmını
gözlemleyince şunu söylemeye başladım
dedim ki bir şey yapmam lazım Çünkü
bakış açım şu sadece eleştiri yapmanın
bir mahiyeti yok o eleştiriyi bir
aksiyonla desteklememiz gerekiyor
diğerinin Benim nazarımda hiçbir önemi
yok Peki ne yapabilirim ben kendi başıma
kendime yeni bir mecra bulabilirim dedim
yani bugün buradaki mottomuzda olduğu
gibi enadır Please ve o mecra
aracılığıyla iletmek istediğim mesajları
bugün konuştuğumuz pp hakkında olabilir
Türkiye'nin diğer problemleriyle alakalı
olabilir bilgiler ve belgeler eşliğinde
insanları anlatabilirim halka
ulaştırabilirim Tamam dedim bunu yaparım
kendime mecra olarak YouTube'u seçtim ve
YouTube'da içerik üretmek için yola
çıktım Ama tabii ki bir problemle
karşılaşıyorum yeni problemimiz şu
bugünkü sosyal medya platformlarının
Algoritma yapısı ve bizim izleyici
alışkanlıklarımız maalesef zihnimizi
doldurabileceğimiz değil zihnimizi
boşaltabileceğimiz içeriklere meyilli
Böyle olunca da benim yaptığım
içeriklerin başta pek bilgi
görmeyeceğini o kadar eminim ki dedim ki
Kadir strateji değiştirmen lazım farklı
bir şeyler yapman lazım ama kendi
çizginden de sapmadan yine bilgiyi
ileterek
o yeni yapacağım konseptle halkla bir
bağ kurup aynı frekansa gelip Ondan
sonra zamanla onlara öğretmek istediğim
anlatmak istediğim diğer şeyleri de
anlatabilirim Çünkü kitle bunu benimser
ve dedim ki ben markaların hikayelerini
anlatmak istiyorum şirketlerin
hikayelerini Çünkü girişimcilik
anlamında bir motivasyon oluşturacak
içinde birçok bilgi var Birçok dinlerken
çıkarım yapmamızı sağlayacak şeyler var
başarı hikayeleri
ve en önemlisi yıllar sonra geri dönüp
baktığımda Türkiye'deki iş dünyasına
dair dijital bir arşiv oluşturmuş
olacağım belgesel niteliğinde bir
külliyat Tamam dedim ben bunu kesinlikle
yaparım başladım içerik üretmeye Biraz
uğraştım ettim üretiyorum falan ama bir
süre sonra tabii ki yine bir problem var
Bu kez de şöyle bir sorunumuz var yine
algoritmalarla alakalı Bu algoritmalar
bir oyuna giriyorsanız O oyunun bir
kuralı var bu mecralarında algoritmalar
sizden sürekli içerik bekliyor eğer
atmazsanız o amacınızı yani mesajı kitle
eleştirmeyi yapamazsınız Fakat ben bunu
yapamıyorum niye yapamıyorum bir
taraftan doktora yapıyorum bir taraftan
içerik üretmeye çalışıyorum Bir taraftan
da bir bankanın genel merkezinde
çalışıyorum
yıllar sonra tekrar bir yol ayrımına
geldim Tıpkı İTÜ İnşaattaki Teknik Resim
dersindeki o sırada olduğu gibi dedim ki
Kadir ya bir taraftan doktora yapacaksın
ve bankada çalışmaya devam edeceksin bu
halka mesaj indirme arzusundan da
vazgeçeceksin ya da gideceksin bankadaki
işini bırakacaksın ve bir taraftan içeri
üretip bir taraftan doktoraya devam
edeceksin
Bu kez yoldan ayrılmayı seçtim adını
hepimizin bileceği dünyaca ünlü bir
bankanın Türkiye'deki genel merkezinde
çalışırken ve o işe Binbir emeğimle
kendi çabamla girmişken bir günde
işimden ayrılma kararı aldım işimi
bıraktım ve YouTube'da aktif olarak
içerik üretmeye başladı O gün işime
bıraktığımda 1800 abonem vardı bugün 180
bin abonem var aslında Türkiye için çok
büyük bir sayı değil ama Misyonu bilgiye
ulaştırmak olan bir kanal için gerçekten
değerli bir sayı fakat asıl önemli olan
şey şu; eğer o gün 1800 abonen varken
ben bu pp konusunu halka indirmeyi
deneseydim mesela Kanal İstanbul'un
hikayesini anlatsaydım o istatistiklerle
o video 200-300 kişiye erişecekti Fakat
daha sonra o video 260.000 kişiye erişti
bir markanın hikayesini anlattığımda
zaman zaman yarım milyon kişiye 600 bin
700 bin kişiye erişebiliyor
Bugün beni buraya davet eden değerli TED
ekibi benim herhangi bir tezimi makalemi
bildirimi okuduğu için beni buraya
çağırmadı bu ppp konusunu şu anda
konuşmamızın asıl sebebi benim bu konu
hakkında YouTube'da yayınladığım
videolar oldu yani onlar beni Aslında
oradan buldu altını çizmek istediğim
vurgulamak istediğim şey şu; eğer bir
mesajımız Varsa ve o mesajı iletmek için
doğru mecrayı bulursak o mesajın
karşılığı bir şekilde yerine ulaşıyor
halk o mesajı alıyor
şimdi İçinizde şöyle düşünenler olabilir
ya Kadir İyi güzel anlattım Bu kadar
şeyi de Türkiye'nin birçok ciddi
problemi var Madem kendini bir şeye bu
kadar adayabilecek derecede bir arzun
var gücün var işini bırakabilecek kadar
bir şeye odaklanma peşindesin o zaman bu
daha ciddi problemlere odaklanmak daha
doğru olmaz mı yani bir bilgi problemi
bilgi problemi tutturmuşsun takılmışsın
peşine diyenler olabilir
Bu soruya Vereceğim bir yanıt var
Türkiye'nin birçok büyük problemim var
Evet fakat Türkiye'nin bütün
problemlerine temel teşkil eden sorunlar
Aslında bugün konuştuğumuz sorunlar
bilginin olmaması bilginin
kullanılmaması paylaşılmaması bilgiyle
değer üretilmemesi neredeyse kimsenin
konuşurken bilgiyle temellendirme
yaparak konuşmaması
televizyonlardaki açık Oturumları meclis
kesitlerini diğer tartışmaları hep bir
şekilde görüyoruz değil mi izlemesek
bile internette vesaire bir şekilde
karşımıza çıkıyor dikkat ediyor musunuz
hep aynı kişiler çıkıyor ve hiçbirisi
konuşurken neredeyse hiçbirisi bir bilgi
veya belge eşliğinde söylediklerini
destekleyecek şekilde konuşmuyor
Ben bu şekilde kim ne kadar Konuşursa
konuşsun hiçbir problemimizi
çözebileceğimizi düşünmüyorum Benim
inandığım şey şu; bizi birey olarak da
ülke olarak da en çaresiz olduğumuz anda
en dibe vurduğumuz anda kurtaracak
yegane şey bilgi fakat hangi bilgi
biliyor musunuz kendimize sakladığımız
değil herkesle paylaştığımız o bilgi
ha hastalığı Benim son sözüm şu; bugüne
kadar Yolumun kesiştiği herkes Bugün
sizlerle yolum kesişti Sizler bundan
sonra hayatımın herhangi bir evresinde
karşılaşacağım veya hiçbir şekilde
karşılaşmayacağım Türkiye'deki Dünyadaki
herkes için tek bir dileğim var
çokça bilgiye sahip olduğunuz o bilgiyi
insani değerlerle ve vicdani unsurlarla
harmanlayıp hepimiz için kullanılabilir
değerler ortaya koyduğunuz uzun ve güzel
bir ömür diliyorum Ben Kadir kuru
bilginin peşinde kendi yolunda
usul usul yürüyen birisi teşekkür ederim